hi
yes it's june meaning it is officially
pride month and if you're like me you're
probably on your 100th watch of
netflix's heart stopper the lgbtq plus
young love story has already been
renewed for a second and third season
one of the show's lead actors joe locke
who plays charlie spring recently joined
the rain with josh smith podcast
where he talked about all things from
his newfound fame societal beauty
standards and the importance of coming
out and living your authentic truth
does this mean we're boyfriends
yes since his newfound fame thanks to
heart stopper lock became a overnight
sensation so much so that even jessie j
stopped her concert to thank him for his
performance in the show and you're
helping someone really close to me it's
a really tough time so thank you
i appreciate you
but for all the good luck has sadly
experienced some online hate and trolls
on the first few weeks i sort of found
myself looking for the bad comments and
looking for
things that would upset me i don't know
why but i think it's a very natural
human thing that people do
um
and so i think i've definitely i found
it i don't i don't look i don't look at
really
twitter as much anymore because or
tiktok or my instagram because i find
that
i find it overwhelming and i find it
quite quite a lot like i can't believe
anyone would have anything bad to say
about joe locke he is an incredible
charlie the young star went on to
explain how unrealistic societal beauty
standards shouldn't be the norm anymore
i saw a um
i don't know it was a tumble thing it
was like oh thank god they haven't cast
the conventionally attractive
um six-pack white male instead of leads
which i get is a compliment but it's a
very backhanded compliment but um and
it's i mean i they're right it's exactly
that it's that's not the norm that's not
the norm at all and we need to show more
of the norm and what is normal because i
think that
especially on like big
tv shows unrealistic
body images are shown
as the norm
[Music]
and also like who decided that was what
we deem as attractive who's decided that
fox that's what we deem as good it's a
big thing coming out it's a big thing
[Music]
telling people
who you are and that's such an important
thing an important healthy thing to show
queer kids and friends of queer kids and
allies and everyone really
take your time
don't rush
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos